an inspired adventure of imagination
traversing the wizarding world
and then there are these fantastic
beasts movies
[Music]
so fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore is the third fantastic beast
movie we have jude law once again
playing younger dumbledore we have mads
mikkelsen playing grindelwald but they
can't actually go against each other
they can't make a move against each
other it's pretty much like chess where
they're both the kings but the king
can't try to take the other king because
that would put the king in check and the
king can't willingly go into check so
the kings have to rely on the pawns and
the rooks and the knights the bishops to
do their bidding now first of all mads
mikkelsen is great he's a legend in
anything he does and i really like mads
mikkelsen as grindelwald i don't like
why mads mikkelsen had to be grindelwald
especially in a world where disney
officially apologized to johnny depp and
they're like we're sorry more and more
it's looking like you know the scenario
in a movie where there's a bomb and
someone has to cut the red wire or the
blue wire and only one is the correct
decision the other one is the incorrect
decision looking like warner brothers
cut the red wire when they should have
cut the blue wire but in a world where
we've had three faces of grindelwald at
this point we've had uh colin farrell
johnny depp and mads mikkelsen although
colin farrell became johnny depp because
it was a disguise you know but still
three faces matt's mickelson brought a
lot to the character and this movie as a
whole i hope he has a great chiropractor
on speed dial because he is gonna have
some hardcore back problems for carrying
this entire movie on his shoulder but
johnny depp is grindelwald he he just
looked off you know i couldn't buy
dumbledore going for this guy this guy
who just screams maniac screams problems
mads mikkelsen comes across exactly how
you would think mads mikkelsen would be
as grindelwald i can see people
following this guy and then at a point
being like i think i got in too deep to
some really bad [ __ ] which you get the
feeling that's what happened with
dumbledore i just think mads mikkelsen
really brought that into focus other
than that this movie's just you know
it happened i guess you see these
fantastic beasts movies i'll give it to
the first one where they tried to do
something new yeah it's like monster
hunter in the wizarding world then they
were like all right let's do some
dumbledore backstory let's let's
concentrate on him now but they're still
trying to hold on to the fantastic beast
element and some of the characters in
theirs there are too many irons in this
fire man especially when one of the main
characters in terms of plot point in
this whole thing is ezra miller who in
terms of screen presence
i'm concerned for the flash movie ezra
miller stands there but doesn't stand
out it's just kind of the mantra but to
its core the problem i have with this
movie other than having too many
characters they need to juggle because
they feel like they have to hold on to
the fantastic beasts characters which
they
kind of do i mean they did set the stage
for the adventure going on now the
problem is i just i don't care because
the movie is not making me care and i
think that comes from a severe lack of
inspiration in terms of creating the
material you look at harry potter harry
potter's imaginative inspired the world
is fleshed out it's building a world
that jk rowling obviously cared about
this just feels like what happens when
warner brothers goes to the richest
woman in the world and goes hey you want
to be the richest
woman in the world cool awesome let's
let's make some [ __ ] up as we go along
why not i'm sure we're going to hear
somewhere that jk rowling had this whole
story of fantastic beasts planned out by
the time she wrote order the phoenix but
i'm just i'm never gonna buy it these
fantastic beasts movies especially at
crimes of grindelwald now secrets of
dumbledore they just come across
as warner brothers making movies so they
can hold on to the intellectual property
of the character i don't know for sure
but you remember that fantastic four
movie that came out eons ago it was a
fantastic four movie that was made
simply because the studio had to make a
fantastic horror movie in order to hold
on to the license of the characters i
really feel like that's what these
fantastic beasts movies are it's just so
warner brothers can hold on to the
rights of the characters so they can
still maintain the rights to the games
and anything that comes out involving
the wizarding world granted j.k
rowling's i guess credited as one of the
screenwriters so that is a flaw that's a
loophole in that argument again don't
know for sure but if i found out that's
why these movies are happening i
wouldn't be the least bit surprised case
in point after
an overly convoluted overly inflated run
time that is this movie there is
something that does deal with elections
you know so it's a wizarding world
election going on is it commentary about
elections in america do not know don't
care but the point is and i'm keep this
vague because i don't want to spoil
anything but the logistics of what's
happening and these wizards going in is
just a world of you know illusions
spells hexes and charms but we're going
to go ahead and buy that i would it just
doesn't make sense the triwizard
tournament has more checks and balances
in place keeping people from putting
their name in the goblet of fire when
they're not supposed to then the
political element of the wizarding world
has it just doesn't make any sense this
movie just doesn't feel like it's a
smooth road leading to a point like the
harry potter books or movies every year
was a story that did feed into the
larger story as a whole that would be
all seven books or seven movies or eight
movies however you want to see it this
movie just feels like a series of all
right these characters are on this
adventure these characters are on this
adventure
newt scamander has this weird animal
thing where he's you know he's doing
this [ __ ] because he knows how to deal
with animals and so right so you have
that so you're reminded oh this is a
fantastic beasts movie but man there are
things that happened in the last movie
admittedly i didn't remember happening
but they happened and they were like
huge things that could have been crazy
character turns and shifts but it
doesn't last long enough in order to be
profound in order for it to matter i've
heard this is the best
of the fantastic beasts movies is it the
best of the fantastic beasts movies
sure but in any case the best of
forgettable is still forgettable mads
crushed it but the problem is now that
i've seen a different person play
grindelwald effectively in each movie
just feels like every movie we get a new
face
of someone we're told is this same
character but it doesn't feel like the
same character just feels like we're
dealing with new people like the crimes
of grindelwald secrets of dumbledore i'm
not gonna remember t minus one day yep
already forgot also one thing i do
remember very clearly dude was the best
part of this movie i feel like he's been
the best part of all the fantastic
beasts movies he's clearly way too good
for this franchise all right so
fantastic beasts and the crimes against
cinematic storytelling
which no it's a play on the previous
movie's title but
who has two thumbs and doesn't give a
[ __ ]
what did you think of the secrets of
dumbledore did you like it did you not
are you disappointed are you done with
these fantastic beasts movies or are you
hooked for the three other movies they
want to make after this whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you